so my I wanted to start with you on this
one because I'm curious what nanny was
like on first read compared to where we
see her in the final film because that
role feels so purely you that I imagine
you had a lot to do with shaping that
character we definitely work together to
figure out who nanny was and it took a
while I have to say I mean I didn't
really know who she was because she's
pretending to be a nanny but you know
they're there this project in particular
felt very friendly and specific toward
each actor when I knew that well was was
going to be Tim I knew I knew what I
knew that what that was this was gonna
be so we tried a lot of hats on nanny
and I think we got some pretty sweet
results cuz she is she's funny and fun
but and a goofball but she's also sweet
and warm but we didn't want her to be
too crazy and then she was British at
one point which was really confusing so
yeah we tried a lot of different stuff
where you landed is spot-on I loved her
and I loved her seeing her influence
transform all the kids - I thought that
played really well yeah well for you I'm
curious what it was like voicing a
fourteen-year-old character because I
kind of couldn't wrap my brain around
the fact that one it sounds like you but
it also feels authentic to the movie oh
that's nice to hear it is I guess that's
the one benefit of having kind of a
higher pitched shrill voice that you can
I've learned you can you can pull off
some some preteens and and early teen
kids no it was it was so much fun to get
to do this the script is so wonderful
and and funny and and sweet and then
also I had gotten to work with Chris
before and just know how
painstakingly he works and makes
everything look super cool too he's he
just knows exactly what he wants and so
sometimes it makes for a longer record
but you know it's worth it because it's
all gonna go into this just really cool
looking thing that you're proud of I was
reading another interview with Chris
where he called this process
slow-motion stand-up so I was just
wondering what you guys thought of that
do you get that feeling at all when you
take so much time to put your voice to a
character and it takes years and years
to see the film through to fruition
definitely slow motion for sure yeah I
mean that's the weirdest element of
animation is the the initial conception
the initial recordings and then as it's
being animated there's more recording
more recording more recording so you
know I can't even remember half of the
stuff that we did and Chris is really
the first I think animation director
that really had took that time and
developed this in this great sense of
humor for the characters yeah I mean
he's really um he's he's he really is
methodical about it and I think it
really pays off um he's he did a
beautiful beautiful job you guys have
both had so much experience voice acting
at this point I'm curious is there
anything you get out of that kind of
performance that maybe you don't get
from a live-action performance that
keeps bringing you back to this medium I
mean you can be anything you want you
know that's the coolest part what were
you gonna say well it's such a different
thing than doing live-action stuff it's
you know you first of all you just when
you go someplace you don't have to get
in a bunch of makeup and wardrobe and
and stuff like that so you're just
you're immediately there and you're
basically starting to talk at the
microphone and it there's just so many
different ways that you can change it
it's you just come back here a little
more surprised by the results a lot of
times
they'll come up with these ideas and it
will maybe alter the dialogue just a
teeny bit but to you and two totally
different things so you when you when we
see the final product
I haven't dab you seen it yet my I
haven't I haven't seen a rough kind of
it
on my computer so it wasn't really like
the the full screening element but I got
to watch it with the kids and they went
nuts safe they loved it I'm so excited
for guys to see the finished product
because it's an assemblage of some of
the scenes and you get to see as as it
as it comes together and the animation
is more and more polished yeah I mean
the the methodical nature Chris also you
know not just with the dialogue and the
script but then the visuals it's just I
couldn't get even just looking at the
hair of these characters yeah so
interesting and cool I'm so excited to
see just everything that you know put
put together well you're pretty much the
guy with the coolest haircuts now
between
this role and also extraordinary two
movies that everybody should be watching
right now well don't forget on last man
there was a lot of body hair cutting as
well
so I guess that's what it was there's a
lot of body hair there's a lot about not
a body haircuts all right guys I have to
let you go but thank you so much for
your time today
okay enjoying the whole beautiful hunka
process thank you thank you very much
you too